i i gotta ask i gotta ask
seems like this is like the hottest
thing on the planet right now
clearly yep so here's why you're not
gonna get offended by this i hope not
but
i remember a time when i was a kid and i
was collecting you know 86 mets and i
was like it was like a big deal i was a
kid and then i grew up and i was more
interested in
hanging out partying chicks the whole
thing
now this is kind of cool again i mean
let's just use what you're saying you're
hanging out with drake you're doing
things with logan paul i saw you on your
instagram you're throwing touchdowns
with tom brady yesterday steve aoki's
opened up a card shop with our boy dan
fleischman like
it seems like the cool kids are in this
market i remember a time my buddy josh
who might be listening
maybe five ten years ago he told me he
was collecting cards i'm like you're a
straight up nerd bro straight up yep
nerd alert
why why is this a cool thing now it's
basically seems like you and the card
game has gone from geek to chic please
explain is it all about the money that's
my question is it just simply it's an
asset class there's money there you know
follow the money the cool kids are in it
now drake's in it what's going on well
it's it's definitely part because if
it's an asset class but it also it gives
you honestly
there are first of all there are people
who just love the cards they love the
look they love the design they get
excited opening up packs but
do you you bet on sports
not anymore okay i've been to ga it's a
problem okay okay so but let's say so
you've got people about sports right yes
that they like sports don't they correct
okay i'm a big sports fan okay don't get
it okay fine so if you if you bet a game
of sports do you feel that you have any
control any control over whether or not
you're going to win that bet
no
well if unless i know uh tim donaghy
yeah if you if you said you did you're
you're lying or you're or you're a
delusional okay because if you bet
sports you know
it's it's the theory is it's 50 50 but
less than 50 because the house takes
money the difference between sports and
cards are is trading cards especially
modern cards could be a little bit like
sports betting however
you actually have some control of your
outcome
you can go out and decide okay fine i am
a baseball expert and baseball is the
best one because uh a lot of people
don't know the young players i can go
out i read the scouting reports i know i
know information about this guy i can
put money into him if you're you know a
basketball player let's say let's say
you went to university of kentucky okay
and let's say you saw tyreese maxie and
you know tyrese maxi went way lower than
he should have in the draft when the
sixers got him in the 20s and you put
money on tyra's maxi when he was you
know some of his cards were fifty
dollars or twenty dollars or five
hundred dollars those cards are about 10
to 30 x
since he was drafted so you when you do
when you do something in trading cards
also it lets you root so all of a sudden
guess what it doesn't matter if you're a
knicks fan you want a bunch of tyrese
maxi cards you're a 76er fan and you
want tyrese maxi to do well so it is
it's like sports betting however it lets
you have more direction it lets you have
more control and it lets you use your
expertise a lot a lot more than betting
a single game okay very good way of
explaining and having and having a fluke
a fluke tip tip ball run back for a
touchdown something like that so so that
is part of the reason part of the reason
is an alternative asset class the other
part of the reason is that breaking
cards has become entertainment you know
i was breaking a box of cards with drake
and i had hundreds of thousands of
people watching i broke a box of pokemon
cards with logan paul over 10 million
people have seen that video on on
youtube so
all of those things have transformed and
when you look at a company like fanatics
i mean here you take a company that had
no sales
no history of sales
no employees and when they initially
went out to take investments i think
they got a four billion dollar valuation
so
that shows you the
what the market thinks and they're gonna
they have so much money invested and
there they have tentacles everywhere so
they're gonna have the players promoting
in the cards the leagues now own a piece
of the company so you're going to have
you know the leagues promoting it and
you're going to have commercials you're
going to have all these things which is
why i like everything that's out of
print because the theory is
if you 5x the market or 10x the market
guess what they have to do they have to
print more product right they've got to
make more product in 2023 24 25 26. so
i'm going back 2019 and earlier and
that's the type of stuff i'm buying
because if they are going to bring all
these new people into the marketplace
they're going to want to buy something
you know that was pre-night pre-2024
right if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]